now go back to the question you have the
question in front of you right they tell
you it's a circle and they tell you one
and only one other piece of information
about it what do they tell you
radius a so if Q can exist there the
locus of Q I just drew the locus of Q by
the way if Q can go through there and
there's a radius of a where is the
center of the circle the focus is the
center isn't it because look that
distance there is a correct and that
also means you can infer from that this
point up here right I'm gonna call this
I'm gonna give it a name I'm going to
call it t okay III can know what the
corner to that point are because that's
that's a diameter that I have going up
through the circle right so where is T
it's gonna be zero comma to a alright
now I'm going to pause for a moment
because we've done a whole lot of
geometric thinking okay I'm going to
leave that diagram there actually I'm
going to finish it off so I can turn off
the projector you can now add some more
into your diagram I've answered the
first part of this question for you like
what does this even mean I haven't even
touched the second part how do you prove
that that really is a circle and there's
not just vaguely circular okay you know
a lot of circle geometry right now you
know a lot of circle properties which
ones are going to be the most useful to
you in proving that that circle is a
circle so I'm going to pause and hand it
back to you guys off you go let's have a
look at this question in terms of how to
use part two because that's really the
key to solve part three that's why
they've done part 1 and part 2 right I
said to you before like you know 15 16
17 different circle properties you
literally can use pretty much any of
them to prove that this is a circle but
in giving you part 1 and 2 they are
assuring you to use a particular kind of
property what did part 2 tell you what
did we conclude from that the gradient
of o to Q which keep in mind because
I've drawn my imaginary lockers here Q
is anywhere on this circle circle
like okay so for instance if Q were here
okay what I now know is that gradient Oh
Q is equal to T okay now in this circle
what feature is o qu what kind of object
is OQ it's a chord right it's a chord
within the circle and I notice that not
only is it a chord but at least the way
I've drawn it
it's a cord that connects to this
diameter do you notice that we've got a
diameter in a circle right and I know
the gradient of this chord so if I had a
look at say this are the chord that's
here then what circle property can I
take advantage of the angle in a
semicircle should be should be
right-angled now I'm just I'm drawing
that right angle there with sort of
tongue-in-cheek cuz I haven't proved
that yet but that's what I expect to be
true okay
if the grading of this is T then I'm
expecting that this will be minus 1 over
T so let's prove it okay I know the
coordinates of this point up here T
right but I need to prove it like do you
remember where I got T this imaginary
point from I have to reason through that
so the way I would say is that note that
when T equals 0 okay you have to be a
little careful with this T you know in a
way of speaking can't actually ever
equal zero look at the question can
anyone tell me why because gradients
gonna be 0 there's some look look again
at the question something specific to
this question T is part of a ratio right
we mentioned this before like 1 to 0
when I was animating it that kind of
thing so it might be better to say when
T approaches 0 right where is it going
well it's going towards oh do you
remember that because look at the here
it is look at the coordinates of Q
you've got 280 and to 8a squared there's
T's in both of these when T is gone
toward zero these things are both going
toward zero right so when T approaches
q approaches the origin is that okay now
if that happened then T is on the other
side so I can say therefore ot is a
diameter where T has these coordinates 0
comma 2 a since like where today where
did I get this number from how did I
work out was 2a and not like say 3a or a
hundred a it was from the it was from
that radius from the focus do you
remember that so where T is that since
the radius is a okay so now I have
established the significance of this t
point to this circle that I'm hoping to
prove now I'm going to go for the
gradient I can say that the gradient of
T Q is equal to all right help me work
it up let's do it
what's the rise this thing here remember
it's a to a T squared on 1 plus T
squared is that correct take away what
to 8 all divided by what's the run in
this case it's 280 on 1 plus T squared
is what we proved earlier minus 0 that's
convenient fractions on fractions gross
what would like me to do multiply
through so that leaves me with 280
squared there there's the 1 plus T
squared that I multiply through by okay
on the denominator that's nothing this
is just that I see a whole lot of two
A's there's one there's one there's one
they're all gone
okay that leaves me with what on the
donor and look carefully what -1 yeah
cuz the T scares are gonna cancel yes
are you okay with that - 1 and what's
left on the denominator how convenient
so I'm not gonna finish this off that
was the crucial piece I can now say AHA
TQ is perpendicular to OQ which means
this is
an angle in a semi-circle because it's
90 degrees hence Q is on a circle bla
bla bla bla bla make sense so what makes
this question difficult what I love
about this question is it's not the
thing that usually makes parametric's
difficult usually the thing that makes
parametric's difficult is how much
algebra you have to deal with like you
you descend into an algebraic rabbit
hole and then you you know you miss a
minus sign then you're like oh no I'm
doomed forever okay this is about
thinking geometrically okay which is
what I love about this question which
also says it's what we as a state are
really bad at that's why we do so badly
this question